hey everybody how's it going i'm john
lucas hopkins i'm joined by
joey
joey uh and we
are playing let's just get right into it
joey
the thing everyone cares about
the game the game dead rising four the
fourth dead rising yep uh it came out
today right
uh scott gave it a seven
uh which is a pretty pretty good score i
like i like it as a seven
yeah you think you think it's good
well personally for me i just really
like dead rising in general i think uh
they have a special place in and not
only gaming but also my heart
yes
i don't know they just they just offer a
lot of joy
and what better way to have the joy than
christmas which is when this game is
that is maybe my that's probably the
thing i'm most excited about this game
is uh i like christmasy
i grew up on charlie brown holiday
specials so the idea of
you know i could just uh get this game i
could sit down i can enjoy it over the
long winter break that sounds really
good that looks like uh kind of funny is
tim gettys
i'm just going to point that out
a little bit
is this uh is this the beginning yeah
okay so this is actually right after the
prologue in which like frank gets
caught by some government agency
[Music]
o christmas tree
o
christmas tree
this is pretty cool yeah
[Music]
there's something funny about the idea
of naming it the memorial megaplex yeah
like yeah this is a
a memorial but also it's still a
shopping mall
[Music]
inviting commentary on black friday
[Music]
that would that's really well made i
like that a lot
scott was uh
one of the things that struck me in
scott's review was he's saying the story
is actually pretty good
which i wasn't expecting
how do you feel about the story i
actually haven't gotten that far i i
haven't beaten the game yet okay um but
i mean from what i've seen so far it's
pretty interesting is that guy's name
hank east
is that his is that his alias
no oh no it's brad no no but the the
name on the door said hank east possibly
which is frank west in cover name
okay
which is pretty good yeah i will work
with others
it's a dumb little joke it's never been
my strong suit
just
got a stuffy in here don't you think
oh fresh air
i really thought that would work
all right well it seems i have some time
in my hands what do you want to talk
about ah i know who you are
colonel brad park
commander of the zdc i'm up on my zombie
news thank you very much of course you
are
well then you also know that the zdc's
mandate is to respond to zombies on u.s
soil yes and confine and silence anybody
who knows the truth they're all up on it
thank you it's happening again in
willamette
what is
an outbreak
i didn't see anything on the news how
long has been going on
six weeks now
really wait a minute i'm just realizing
this this is like a die hard two
scenario
actually never seen diehard two well in
die hard too
the same thing happens to
uh
um john mcclane where it's on christmas
again and he has to deal with the
situation again
and there's a part where he's like how
does the same [ __ ] happen to the same
guy twice and i'm getting that vibe real
strongly right now the only reason i
found out is because somebody's saying
is frank west is the john mclean of
video games
um
he's pretty close i think reservist
training i don't know if that's actually
terrorists he got zombies
i like to make a bold claims like that
all communications in and out of the
town are gone
now the satellite photos have been
updated in four months
it is being covered up
but
all that pales in comparison
to the mystery of why you frank west
are teaching a goddamn night class
instead of being two steps ah to me on
this
i quit
you quit
yes
i quit
do you know how many outbreaks i've been
part of how many i've covered and what
thanks have i got huh nothing
no thank you no flowers just a contact
point oh yes chat thank you uh
let's see here uh any any questions from
the chat please let us know uh people
ask about you expose the first one
nick from dead rising three nick ramos
do you know if he's in this game
is a few letters behind your name do you
know when this game takes place in
relation
well this
the other games
15 years after the first dead rising
involvement and i don't think nick is in
this at all
it's just only frank i think because
dead rising three took place a decent
clip after uh
two because it features um you do it
right chuck green is like an older man
and his daughter's like growing up in
that game a lot more stake here than
just one town
oh
no
i'm out
whoever breaks this
they're in for some big gains
one thing i'm a little something
they seem to be doing okay job with him
but something i liked about
frank west a lot is i liked his goofy
nature he had a
like a dumb pudgy face he had a really
goofy voice yeah um he's one of your
students isn't it and they've
oh okay well uh
i think you
oops
okay
[Music]
uh but i liked
i liked how uh
i liked how goofy he was and they seem
to they have changed his voice after
they've changed his face and
i don't know i i don't like it when
games do that because there's like a
you lose what makes that character
what people liked about that character
in the first place yeah
i understand but i think the fact that
it takes place so long after and he is
older
so like
crazy he's gonna change
all right you know i still like his
characters here too
he's just became funny enough to to make
me not really think about like
his too much about his voice acting okay
all right you don't see his face too
much and it's still it's still at the
very least kind of looks like him in the
first game yeah i mean that's gonna
really
depend on you as a person and your and
your love for that original character
uh people ask what we are playing this
on uh this is on xbox one xbox one yeah
so it is available also on
pc windows 10.
it's not up on steam yet
so it's going to be that right yeah well
we don't know quite yet uh so it is a
timed exclusive um for the first 90 days
i think
um so beyond then we might see it on
like steam or even i imagine eventually
uh dead rising three went to uh
are the guns better in this game
some of them are that was always uh i
mean you know the original the guns were
uh
just a horrible mask control uh which is
kind of the point
and i know they've cleaned them up in
like i think three was a lot better
about
zombies are the them
oh bagel
bagel and coffee need that
i already just covered in blood
you seem to be uh
not so fragile
uh no it doesn't seem that way i mean it
could just be the the opening sequence
but i remember the original game right
let's get out of here you were you were
very fragile and you could die
really easily uh which of course was a
uh
huge bummer because
when you you know the way that game
works with saves and stuff you die
you're you're in
trouble can you save any any point you
have to go to a specific uh same house
well there are check checkpoints um
looks good
three star's the best
you ever stop clowning
i should take a good look around like
one thing that they did change if people
already noticed it is that like you know
there's no timer and
you're it feels like you're just pretty
free to do
whatever you want
which i
i again i'm personally conflicted on
that one where i
actually really liked the timer i think
that that is sort of a big part of what
made dead rising like
so unique and weird
but
i also understand how the people who
just wanted to kind of explore around
and and
interact with stuff how that really kind
of took away from the game
okay group
[Music]
yeah
you won't need to uh escort survivors
i'm not sure no escort missions at all
oh man no frank the pimp
how are the achievements sadly no that's
what i want to know how are the
achievements are they wacky
i haven't seen too many no not yet
because if there is man
the original dead risings legacy for me
is in it
it was one of the first games that i
thought really like got weird with its
achievements in a way that
i think kind of showed achievements
could be more than just
beat this level beat that beat this
difficulty like you can actually do
interesting things with them
as a later save we might be jumping into
at that point
um yeah we could we can always jump to a
later one i just wanted to kind of show
them all maybe go through like a little
bit of that first sure yeah
uh i noticed we got this weird
mayan theme going on here oh this is the
this is the amazon food court
that's a
very elaborate food court
it's like i really like the new mall
it's it's a lot bigger
and it has like a bunch of different
themed areas to it so later on you'll
see like a there's a
caribbean cove
so it's all pirate themed
are you
so this is even though it is the
wilmette mall it's not they didn't
because the first mall blew up at the
end of the first game
they did not recreate them all
exactly the way it was like this is a
different mall i guess
is it a lot bigger would you say it's
quite big yeah
they have a freaking hotel in here oh my
god wow yeah this is a swanky mall
sorry i had to stop for a samosa
samosa
hey
hey
come over here before they see you there
we go here's some guns
all right grab a gun
i got a [ __ ] ton of them
propane tank
can we get a room separate beds though
oh
you're hilarious you know technically
speaking you'd be our first guest what
do you mean
are you guys from out of town or
something
all this [ __ ] started on black friday
which not coincidentally was the day
after the grand opening sale you're
saying this model wasn't even open one
day before it got destroyed by zombies
we gotta move that door lead to the
maintenance hallway
uh weapon crafting oh wow okay already
into it so there's a crossbow in the
grenade so i have a blambo now we got
trouble
so yeah i noticed you just did that on
the fly yeah
uh you do no longer have to go to
uh
the um
uh workbenches anymore to do it nope
that's just are those just dudes with
guns
those are
yeah there's like zombies and then
there's like some soldiers uh littered
throughout the the mall as well is there
do you know
why they're trying to kill you
i think they just don't like people
in general
seems reasonable
oh
oh sure those guys are dead now i
noticed a little uh
animation got stuck there
uh nat time on twitch wants to know how
far we're into this we just uh this is
the opening
part of the game right here we're just
kind of showing off the beginning uh we
do have a save that we'll go to later to
kind of show
uh you know some more cool weapons and
and other stuff
yeah
we're good okay let's go
get some glasses here
oh yeah just
ah [ __ ]
all right distinguish frank
i'm connor by the way yeah nice to meet
you i'm investigating the outbreak you
know anything about how it started i
know these military
three [ __ ] regarding something super
secret near the mall front entrance
uh devil st on youtube asks if we've
done a review yet
we have uh scott butterworth reviewed
the game he gave it a seven you can go
check it out joey uh did the video
review he edited it uh it's very good
you should go watch that might be some
weapons there good plan toy cannon what
can you do with that toy cannon i can
pick it up
another thing i liked about dead rising
was half of the weapons were not useful
i remember the cds you could pick up
like a cd yeah you're just like throwing
you're chucking cds at people
and it would take like
10 cds to maybe kill a zombie and it was
not effective at all but good luck to
your west really fun
okay here i know a couple of uh
a couple of weapons we can do the
electric wreath okay
yeah oops
come on
yep all right there we go
it's a combo
what are you comboing it with um i think
you can do that with anything electrical
i forgot what i had at first but
let's go find the mobs what do you do
what do you do with it
take it
stick it on someone
okay
and then like everyone around them
interesting there we go
what would you say is your your favorite
weapon so far
um there's a combination actually a
combination uh
golf cart and a segway
okay wait i'm trying to picture this in
my head so
it's like
how do you combine a golf cart in a
segway those are two things with wheels
man i don't know how he combines these
things there we go what i'm trying i
don't even know what that looks like
is is one of them on top of the other
you just
go carton ladies and gentlemen
oh there's so many in the way
it's really gonna affect your uh your
time
let's go make it only got two laps to go
uh killer mike on twitch yes this game
is out it is available today
uh you can get it over on xbox one or
windows 10
uh not steam yet uh it is a timed
exclusive so
eventually it will be but right now it's
not
at least that's the idea
i also hope it'll it'll end up on uh ps4
as well yeah
um i mean laura croft did
that is a shopping cart you should get
in that
do that
i like how that's your two potential
prizes like oh you want the race car or
do you want the shopping cart no i want
both
that's why they put them together
the best of both worlds yeah the
kilowatt
it was just an electrified uh oh wait
okay so what
there's a couple extra bits attached to
that that those two things didn't have
like these
yeah
ornaments i don't think you could just
by combining those two you can make that
i don't think that's how that works
uh somebody was saying if you could
combine the toy cannon with the fire
extinguisher you get something okay
uh
daisy morgan yes this is on the xbox
okay there was the uh
segway right there let me actually get
that one
oh segway
balancer as they call it all right
can they not
is that a thing can you not call i think
can you not call it a segway yeah i
guess i did it
yeah
still run people over with this oh my
god those looters
oh
all right well
all right where's that golf cart
yeah you're kind of just mowing them
down
it doesn't really seem to be like a
threat
let's get stuck on here okay i think
it's over here somewhere
and so here's the uh the caribbean cove
section of the mall oh yes so you can
see like it's all pirate themed and
there is a big pirate ship whoa that's a
lot of dudes oh man
we got to do something with them
what is it are they good um
uh oh what are they called the insane
people
they called maniacs maniacs
didn't they not call them is that what
they called they were called psychopaths
psychopaths yes uh are there any good
uh maniacs in this one there's there's
one a little bit later like once we get
out of the mall we can go to i mean i
you know the first one i always remember
uh the clown with the two chainsaws the
um
prison inmates in the vehicle outside uh
which were just the worst those guys
were awful
there's the uh
the sun it's the dad and his two sons
with the sniper rifles i don't remember
that one yeah they're like like the
dad and there's like the dad and the in
the sun and they're like a real jerk to
the other son who's like this like
slightly pudgier
they're like really mean damn okay here
we are
this is the uh the bogey monster so
that's the the segway and the golf cart
so it turns into this all right i'm not
really sure
and then okay it's got
blade no they're golf clubs
interesting yeah and then for some
reason it has this
uh what
okay you're gonna have to explain that
one to me i i could i could not neither
a segway or a golf cart can do
that golf balls down
oh he's stuck
just bail out
let's find a fire extinguisher i want to
combine that with the uh
should be one somewhere here right yeah
you feel like a mall there should be a
fire extinguisher
you know fire code safety regulation
yeah see
it's working kind of stuff like that i
like dumb
weapons that don't work
or eventually they will
it actually killed them
mandoka in the chat wants to know how
big is the game world
i can't really compare it to anything
offhand but i will say it is pretty big
the mall itself is is
quite spacious but the entire
temperature oh perfect uh
would you
um how would you compare to the other
dead rising games
i mean they've all been progressively
getting bigger like one two and three
would you say this is the biggest or
maybe like
uh on par i don't i don't i actually
didn't play three so i couldn't tell you
the scale of three exactly
yeah i don't know either thanks again
about this right frank
that's vick's handwriting on the wall so
here's some uh i like the story parts of
it
yeah
like it's kind of like a batman
or the the new batman games where there
are it's like detectives yeah you have
to take a picture of certain things
yeah oh i was gonna ask about the camera
um how's the camera on there
it's pretty cool
so we got a couple different filters
that we can also go through it's a very
futuristic looking camera there so we
got just well apparently he just uses
all film cameras but it looks like that
looks a little
something about that doesn't look right
i've been here for weeks
so we got a spectrum analyzer which can
detect like you know secret messages
written or even fingerprints and we also
got night vision which can like see in
the dark
we can also
oops where was it
there we go take a selfie yeah
all right
i'm okay with that i saw some people i i
think that's a that's a dumb thing that
frank west would do
i think she
uh feels very uh
passionately about us
this is military hardware it looks like
vic's been using its uploaded ports
all right i want to see this thing so
the outbreak started at the malls well
this one is a
grenade
and the sledgehammer apparently i i
guess i don't have the blueprint for
whatever the uh the canon
fire extinguisher yeah like the
blueprints are scattered all throughout
the world and you'll gradually start
picking them up i have a bunch but not
all of them
well that's
maybe i'm wrong but
i thought the way it worked in two was
you could always build
you could just try combining stuff and
you could figure it out and you could
still make it but having the blueprint
got you like a better version of it
okay these are uh these are the new
zombies right the fresh ones
don't go down very easily
as you can see so is this kind of their
like their way to put in your like fast
you know left for dead zombies
okay maybe with this weapon they do
all right
now oh no
[Music]
okay i'm just
thinking about the propane tank
now
get out of here
oh the parking
i thought this thing came oh nice
that's cool
these cars just go flying with this
i spent many hours in the original game
in the parking lot because it was the
best way to grind zombies if you wanted
to get the achievement
yeah the physics on that thing is whack
are there any good um
i want to see some outfits
that's another thing about dead rising
if anyone in the uh chat has questions
for us about dead rising 4
uh please let us know i'm also curious
uh what is
everyone's favorite dead rising game
uh mine probably would be
one
uh
for like nostalgia but i think maybe two
i think mechanically two is probably the
best um two probably hits that sweet
spot
but uh
there's something about like one when i
first played it that was like so
weird
and out there that i uh i really like
that one a lot
crap come at me
can you do the uh the crowd hopping you
could do in one
they took it out yeah it doesn't look
like it it was only in one and they like
they took it out of two
it was really satisfying though just
jump on their heads it was i really like
that about it
frank got something you might be
interested in vic has been using
terminals to bypass the communications
blackout yeah i think i saw it uh mandu
wants to know how long is the game do
you have any idea how long the game is i
think scott beat it in about 20 hours or
so okay um but there's always reasons to
come back yeah that seems like a decent
because when you start a new game again
you keep all the weapons and all the
blueprints you have
just revisit them okay yeah
finding all the the weapon combos is
something that's i feel like it's for
completionist it's pretty fun
all right we uh have gone too long
without getting an outfit yes ooh
sportster sports yeah so let's see what
what are we feeling basketball
football i'll try to find some more
let's go with football for now keep an
eye out for those terminals okay it's
middle of the football season right all
right yeah mm-hmm sewer shirts yes
sports
that seems good yup protect your head
small helmet
shorts are here somewhere can you unlock
um different like moves for frank that
was another thing you could do and yeah
so he has a whole like skill
tree that you can
spend your points on
i currently have 13 so
and where are they
uh someone in the chat is wondering if
all the dead risings take place in the
mall no um
first one takes place in a mall the
second one is like a mall casino which
is a
i think a pretty good way to one-up a
mall yeah uh two takes or three takes
place in
kind of like open city right yeah
um and then this one takes place in a
mall but it also does actually have
outside of them all right yeah so we
will get to that in like just a hot
second but yeah it does have like a
pretty big uh
city part to it the mall is is big but
the city is much larger i think okay the
all right i guess we're going baseball
do it
and golf club
you know just a whole sports person
really yeah
ooh kitchen knives can you throw knives
at people i don't think so oh actually
you know what let's just
forget the sport outfit okay this is
what we came here for
all right toy store
okay
you're gonna get the dino head on right
yeah i'll get it just a second
um
uh one person's asking if there is co-op
yes but it's different in this one right
yeah
so we can actually maybe later on like
towards the end of the stream we can
play uh play around the co-op is that
how to find a match uh yeah you know
split screen now right no there's no
split screen but you play with uh three
other people okay yeah yeah so the
co-op's like a separate mode in this one
it's not um you could just bring people
in which that was something i did like a
lot about too was uh you could really
like goof around and yeah with your
friends in the mall and co-op
i mean you can still do that here it's
just that it's not you know it's more
objective based and like each session is
kind of short but yeah it's still pretty
fun okay
uh
mondo wants to know if we've tried the
game on pc is it well optimized
i haven't tried it on pc but i imagine
it's pretty good just based on the xbox
one version where it's
there there are so many zombies on
screen at once but it never seems to be
slow or
well hey there never feels like it it's
struggling it never feels like a chugs
at all
what did you just say to me a man is in
a suit of armor well
if queen sandra is half as impressed as
she sounds then she's my kind of lady
you'll pay for that
your mother was a gopher and your father
smells a body spray hey open up so i can
teach this old fart a lesson
you can get the suit of armor right
of course
good lord
i'm grabbing this over here yes
get that thing
all right everybody welcome to our dark
souls run
keeping the helmet though
it's a weird dark souls game it says
it's a flaming helmet why isn't it on
fire yet
uh tara the punisher wants to know was
it a good idea or a bad idea to remove
the time limit in dead rising for uh
kind of talked about that earlier but i
think that sort of depends on
your perspective i
feel mixed about it i liked the timer
um but i know a lot of people who like
hated the timer
uh and it was really offered to them or
spencer mentioned how he like could not
he just did not like the games at all
with the timer yeah i felt i actually
feel that the same way in that like i
feel the timer is uh i guess it's better
suited for people who
where the timer was like
how do i say this
if you want to just like goof around a
lot like the timer uh it it restricts a
lot of that
i think and that's what i like doing i
just like
going from place to place not worrying
about much other than like finding the
goofiest crap to put on and
use as weapons
and killing zombies with it intimidated
by you maniacs because i am alive this
is our turn
is that how you're gonna take care of
them yeah all right
i want to see this play out
they're not really attacking you though
i think it might be because i'm on a
tricycle
i understand that it's very threatening
uh someone wants to know if this has uh
as much or more combos than three
uh
i did not play three so i would not know
that is a good question
it has close to 50 of them though as far
as i know okay well
that's just happened
now nick seems to think the outbreak
started at the mall's front i like that
the uh the voice has uh
it's like it's muffled yeah because he's
wearing the that's a good touch
pit stop real quick uh the wu yes i
agree with what you're saying man i i
like the
i like the tension of the timer where
i um
i actually get kind of bored of games
that are like nothing but goofy um
i i
rather a game
[ __ ] uh have its goofiness sort of
like
when the goofiness happens more uh
bit by bit i find it's like more
rewarding for me when that goofiness
happens but a game where
you're just given unlimited goofy
freedom it's uh i don't know i get bored
of it really quickly
god i hate christmas
i mean i always
i always felt like the the middle ground
solution was this is great by the way
this is a toy crossbow that's not going
to do anything
i thought like a good middle ground
would be keep the timer in the game but
then have just a
like a free-roam mode
for the people who just want to goof
around and like don't care at all like
just give them that mode
that's how i always felt it was kind of
like the way they should have gone
personally
make our way out of the mall
yeah i want to see outside the mall
whoa something major going on
you don't see me right
i don't too suspicious no yeah
my toy crossbow
i don't know how i feel about guys with
guns i know it feels weird to use a
weapon
like
bullets here
and he's just taking those bullets
anytime you fought to do with guns it
was the
man this is the worst thing ever
there we go
all right yeah yeah you got it oh get
that minigun uh so
i can't
because um there are certain weapons in
the game where you can only pick it up
if you have the exo suit
um interesting so that is like a little
robotic thing to help you like to help
your body like pick up
heavy things
like the uh
like the power armor and fallout yeah
kind of interesting
wait
did he do that with his camera yep you
can see fingerprints
it's not
i thought you said he had film film
doesn't do that
well set my balls on fire what the [ __ ]
happened here
no okay yeah
so it was like these investigative parts
what do you gotta
figure out what went wrong that's cool i
like that
ooh just some chemicals good old
chemicals can eat them
throw them
all right this guy
or woman
military [ __ ] were investigating
what happened here
uh craig scott says does this support
the companion app i'm not actually is
there a companion app for this game i i
actually have no idea
remember that was like a thing remember
for a while there was like a couple
years there where
every game would have like an app you
know it was like microsoft's thing or
what was it no there's microsoft thing
but also um
games would just have like a standalone
app you could get like the division or
you know or like gta 5 gta 5 uh
metal gear solid 5 had one
soldiers didn't do this i feel like
zombies we actually no games this year
did that i think everyone
kind of gave up on that i've been trying
to get in here for weeks
wait holy [ __ ] go back go back hi
what are you doing that dude
calm down pal looks like frank west that
looks like that looks like he looks more
like original pudgy frank west
that's one for the scrapbook
like am i crazy that guy looks more like
frank west than frank west
it's pretty close it's special
he's even got a camera
hey buddy apparently like another photo
journalist yeah is he just like a frank
west like oh
yeah okay frank west dude he's the uh
he's the conrad verner of the dead
rising universe darcy we should totally
if anyone gets that reference share the
story good on you
seriously hey oh you have to meet my
girlfriend uh i mean editor paula she's
she's got a podcast it's a really
popular podcast she's been investigating
so does everyone do this guys for weeks
obscurus
that's the name of this outfit yeah
paula's an expert on them you know
actually i'm surprised he's taking this
man seriously your girlfriend where is
she uh i i think she's at city hall uh
strider in uh twitch asks is this game
early access nope it is out
today it is out today
damn
yeah it's it's gonna be great
see you around
cool
yeah
well oh
yeah i'm just gonna
yeah i want to see i want to see more of
the open world here
razzle you are correct it is
conrad werner is from mass effect
age 52 man he's old
uh all right
if his friend went to save your will
yes though i also answered hey [ __ ]
or frank who
yeah i'm paula as in the undead gospel
of it's my zombie podcast doctor gave me
your number
oh bro oh boy i hear
[Music]
i mean okay this guy has a first aid kit
and a sandwich in his trunk the other
guy had a battle axe
two weird people in this mall
that guy's got a saw blade
i don't know i think all these people
have their priorities in order you
come over here hand are you gonna
combine those two things yeah
it makes sense right it just
it is now smaller than it once was he
just turned into a warthog
i only took shop class to meet girls
well i think my chances are better on my
own all right the door give it a try uh
thanks
what ifs i'll open the gate for you uh
joseph wants to know can you play xbox
live on this it does have uh
the online co-op mode that's it though
right is there any other
is that all the the two modes is it just
the co-op in the campaign yeah
[Music]
all right this ver this reminds me of
what i've seen of dead rising uh three
just kind of this open world
uh both of them took place at night too
which yeah i feel
i feel mixed about yeah i i
something i noticed oh my god and just
the mall in the setting in general is
the first game took place during the day
uh well it took place during the day it
took place over three days so it
actually did have a night but you would
that's awesome all right i'm into that
does it run out of ammo no
seems a little broken
[Music]
but uh i i like
i like it during the day too because
it's you know like it's a little bit
brighter a little bit more open you can
see better
yeah the darkness especially in the mall
in like enclosed areas is really really
dark
well a little little much you ask me
we are streaming it on xbox
so here's a little christmas tree and
you were asking about maniacs before
right yeah yep so there is one here
i can show you
they always had like really good wacky
cut scenes and uh they just always came
off as like
they're like fun fun little stuff
uh someone wants to know what the uh
level cap
um is question
might be 100 actually really
i'm not even that far into the game and
this one's already i'm already at 39. i
really played it all that much okay wow
alrighty
what's this
uh somebody uh wants to know how it is
optimized on pc we haven't checked out
the pc version apparently you said the
uh dead rising three was horribly
optimized even on high ends i didn't
play dead rising three at all so i
wouldn't know
um
but yeah i uh this may be something to
look into it at some point
oh that is not creepy at all
why are those there
it's not like the zombies made them look
like that i think they're already they
were just already creepy
why would you do that
where's the maniac
i thought he would show up here
hello
maybe they only show up at specific that
was another thing like we'll dead rising
to that where
things would show up at specific times
and and stuff like that
uh but there's no timer in this one so
good point i don't know
uh terry the punisher i love the idea of
dead rising 4 in christmas i think
that's a
great
especially where
you know i want to say the games have
gotten stale stale but uh
it's the fourth game right you gotta mix
it up a little bit and i think
uh the idea of setting it at christmas
is a great hook
for sure yeah and it seems like they're
taking advantage of it in a way that i i
really appreciate it
um and you know what
i think it works because i'm excited to
like spend my winter break
playing this game yeah good point yeah
sit down with a nice cup of cocoa
play this game
i think it fits in so well with the the
maul aesthetic too
it's like
just bringing it back to the mall and
having the outbreak happen on black
friday
yeah so
do they
i think i do they try to make like a
real serious attempt at like
you know
fighting commentary on consumerism or is
it pretty like surface level i mean you
still have to pay for the game so
i mean that's a good point this this
game is coming out within the holiday
season so
i guess any sort of uh
consumerist anti-consumers message
they're they're making
kind of kind of falls away a little bit
somebody in the chat wants to know
what's up with the outfit we're wearing
it's a business suit
for the professional woman
also a reindeer outfit a reindeer mask
yeah
yeah
i got a supply crate yeah so here's the
exo suit here oh you'll find them
scattered throughout the land
is it a limited use thing like once you
put it on it unfortunately yes but it's
pretty freaking cool
oh and then they even give you a thing
you can
like the weapon okay so i see the power
down there in the corner the weapons
i think
the best part is that you can go up to
certain things
and just pull them out of the ground or
oh vending machines all right i wasn't
expecting that that's awesome
uh the cut scenes are rendered in game
right it's like when you're wearing a
ridiculous outfit it will always yeah
awesome
always follow you that was another thing
i loved was just you're wearing
you know
just the dumbest thing and it's like a
real serious cut scene well serious
cutscene but you know
can you take this thing
nope
i'm gonna find something to pick up with
this
all right uh do we want to hop into a uh
later safe and
uh show off
some cool
uh interesting combo weapons
um
let's see what can i make now actually i
mean the the combo weapons
persist is just a matter of okay so we
actually have them all yeah oh gotcha
okay i see i see
what happens when it runs out
yeah just my body
oh wow all right now
you're now naked
i got i
what in the stream yeah uh we are at 11
51
um
what are you thinking i mean if you want
we can try and hop into a game of uh
co-op co-op multiplayer yeah we want to
show that off oh that's a lot of zombies
i know
oh if only we had like something
you know what
i will say yeah that is uh the amount on
screen and
the frame rate seems to be
completely solid
i got a couple more
shots left here
okay i feel like you missed
all right well yeah we can
yeah we'll see if we can get a game of
multiplayer
it is launch day though so we'll see
whoa okay oh
we could just we'll see if anyone's
playing back into the main menu
was there a teddy bear head is there is
there a teddy bear head you can wear
teddy bear head
i want to say yes okay cool cool let's
see these are all the characters we can
choose from
let me be this guy
you're gonna be off brand uh
uh colin from uh
kind of funny
and we'll say the multiplayer is
it's very it's very similar to the main
game okay are you the you're basically
given a couple challenges like each
round there's maybe about five or six
within each round and it's either kill
the certain amount of zombies or
complete this task with them
i mean you're pretty much doing the same
thing which
is not is it's not too
i want to say creative
okay
but i mean you can't understand the joy
of just having four people running
around on those like golf carts or sure
like shopping things and just
want people over
oh wow um that person is already level
51 i was actually going to ask what the
level and career points
a tribute to do you know how that how
that stuff works i think it's
i don't know i guess it's only for
multiplayer these people might be
might have had the game for a while i
guess who knows
level 51 jeez
uh
all right so yeah so skull bearer uh
game looks fine for us uh super smooth
uh might just be choppy on your end
but the game has a really excellent
frame rate actually
very impressive there was someone in
chat i think their name was happy face
um they were they were asking about the
uh
the darkness of the game and yes the the
regular game is extremely dark
but in multiplayer it's daytime so as
you can see right here it's just bright
as all hell
i need a weapon
[Applause]
gotta photograph some uh
some sculptures here
okay
that's fun that's cute
i asked hammond if we could open a bar
you know to try and lift everyone's
spirits
she uh she seemed receptive i wonder
where my party went
that was one person well you can see him
on the map yeah
i think so like group attacks you can do
uh i don't think so no okay
skull bear wants to know what the native
resolution is on the xbox one i do not
[Music]
just like freezes them
my team is putting in work we got five
out of five sculptures photographed
the doom gong all right that'll summon
the boss
ooh is it a zombie boss or a maniac
um pretty sure it's a maniac
okay is it uh are they different from
the maniacs from the story are they like
kind of retreads um they're they're i
think they're the same yeah okay
some weapons got a grenade taco
taco
yeah this looks pretty good
let's go okay all right all right that's
pretty good
i gotta catch up to my team
oh that's a good question if you freeze
people with the ice sword but you don't
kill them do they unfreeze after after i
think so yeah okay i saw one that was
just moving around but he was still blue
those guys don't come back though the
ones i run over with no no that guy
definitely doesn't come
i'm back my way
oh yeah we haven't seen this part of the
mall yet did you just sleep
maybe here's the kichiro plaza which is
the the japanese themed section of the
mall oh
yeah oh
oh i just saw a bunch of street fighter
stuff
oh please go into that so you know we're
going in there
oh yes
i'm glad we made it here there's no way
we could end the stream without checking
this door out
can you not put him
on
oh no
you can't put on stuff in co-op oh that
sucks
that's a bummer
oh that was a street fighter sweater
aren't there the christmas
i had the christmas sweater a lot
i'm gonna make frank wear that
that's kind of a bummer you can't
actually
dress up and co-op yeah
oh well um for the campaign
it's the gong
there it is
he's missing
they're just over there having fun
okay
santa claus
of course there's a
there has to be a maniac
that just you know that's how it is
it's destroying him with these flying
lanterns
they just shoot fire
yeah you seem to be working santa real
good
i mean these guys
these guys are level 36 and 51 i think
oh that's true that's a good point
open up let's see what we got
toastman wants to know if the street
fighter arcade machine is playable
probably it is not but you can pick it
up okay you can pick it up though
where did that fire extinguisher go
that's how we just slide
all right
she's got to kill him right now
all right we got 30 other 50.
damn
some thor overstep chainsaw
that's not a chainsaw
there we go
i said i can't just hold it in front of
me just run into him
and it's a little weird
animation on it seems kind of off
i think it'll stick to this
uh some people are complaining about the
brightness that's not that's just the
game
the game is extremely dope the game is
extremely dark uh
which is definitely a complaint i have
towards it is uh it's more just need to
be brighter i know tom is crazy and
maniacal but i have mad respect for his
beer growing skills he's like
practically canadian
i don't even know this guy's this
he's talking about
he's just rambling
is orange juice still the best uh
the best thing to drink in the game for
help
[Music]
all right you just gotta get to the safe
house i think you're done right uh
where is it oh it's upstairs
that's upstairs so do you have access to
the whole mall or only like segments
just segments of it it's like this uh
these stairs are actually gated off like
before we finish this mission
rival schools machines and even a zero
costume which i cannot put on sadly
i like to pretend just because we're
playing multiplayer yeah but you can in
the full game bottle as a trophy what is
this dude even
man dude what is this guy saying
oh you got dude you got a timeline you
got to go oh i met i'm at the safe house
i'm the first one here
i don't know where everyone else is i
like that the safe house is
an arcade that wasn't our mika
oh you can buy stuff here yeah i'm gonna
get these
well you probably don't you're probably
done though right
yeah i'm done but still look at that
that's cool
that's pretty dumb dr dougie fresh
paige and dr dougie what are you oh my
oh good question uh the wu wants to know
where's jill sandwiches
[Music]
sadly enough no jill sandwiches
multiplayer day two survived
is that a new thing xbox does where uh i
noticed the achievement just popped up
in the corner now i think if there's
stuff in the middle of the screen it
might go into the corner or i wonder if
that should be how it is like games can
choose that huh that's weird i've never
noticed that ever uh interesting all
right well i think that is
uh gonna do it for dead rising four the
game is available today on xbox one
and uh windows 10 if you want to pick it
up uh we gave it a seven out of ten uh
you seemed to think that was a pretty
reasonable skill
i think my some of my favorite games are
seven out sevens out seven out of tens
um so
fun it's a stamp of approval approval
yeah this looks like a fun little romp i
might pick it up over the holiday break
uh mostly because i like christmas stuff
so yeah so thank you for watching
everybody and
see you later
you